bill ben bernanke is going to work as an
adviser to your former colleagues news
of the day why is that a good move for
PIMCO well duh you know when I was at
PIMCO
we hooked up with Alan Greenspan sure
and he came for four or five years every
quarter and we have discussions and
dinners and and so on I think it's a I
think it's a good move from from that
standpoint obviously it's a public
relations effort to you it's a public
relations effort
well of course don't you know to be able
to hook up with Ben Bernanke I think it
is that that was one of the reasons one
of the reasons why we did it with Alan
Greenspan but we found out you know that
there were some very positive benefits
to it it's like what kind of value can a
former Fed Chairman provide well he can
provide and she can provide you know at
some point they can provide if anything
a sense of what the Fed thinks in terms
of how they approach you know a
forward-looking problems such as
inflation too low or the real economy
too low and so that's helpful it doesn't
mean you got to buy in and I don't buy
into the current right fed approach but
at least you know what they're thinking
and and it's a good example to always to
not fight the Fed but as I put on a
coffee mug long ago to to be very afraid
so you hire them if you could I don't
think so wife I've moved on in terms of
my personal experience and you know I'm
more than glad to read his weekly blogs
and and get information that way and to
spend the rest of my time in markets is
it right bill for a former public
official and let's recognize there are a
few public officials who've held as much
power there's been Nike did to trade on
that experience speaking you know
speaking engagements and meetings for
250,000 dollars a shot and presumably
millions more with the gig that he's
just signed on to at PIMCO and of course
the other one that set it out
well I think it's the acceptable
standard I mean Fed Chairman right books
politicians write books sometimes before
they're elected a lot of times
afterwards you know politicians move on
to K Street in terms of Lobby land and
and so whether it's right or not it's
imbued I think in our existing ethic
that they should do that it sounds like
you you have a sort of lukewarm feeling
about it well I have a lukewarm feeling
about politicians and their lobbyists
and pastries I can I can really sing you
on that one but you don't have time